e stato un vero privilegio per me oggi
poter passeggiare per le strade di
matera e pensavo che noi da italiani
quasi prendiamo per scontato posti così
magici dove veramente il nostro passato
un passato glorioso e antico e lì e lo
vediamo e ci viviamo ancora in mezzo e
non è solo una cosa italiana perché
proprio il mediterraneo che spesso
chiamato la culla della civilizzazione
io lavorando ad al jazeera spesso vado
anche nei paesi della sponda sud del
mediterraneo e ovviamente cosa c'è
l'antico egitto ci sono i territori
palestinesi israele la terra santa
la siria dove all'epoca ed ossia la
città dove c'è stata abitazione
continua più antica in tutto il mondo e
anche magari restando dalla sponda
europea e poi vediamo anche grecia la
grecia e con la sua storia
però mi ha fatto anche pensare che un
passato glorioso
non è ovviamente una garanzia di un buon
presente e forse anche di un buon futuro
perché guardiamo questi paesi l'egitto
che sta cercando di avere una democrazia
che funziona e che si giusta e che fino
a ora più o meno sta fallendo la sirena
ne parliamo neanche straziata da una
guerra civile che ormai va avanti da
anni non si vedeva fine non si vede fine
la grecia colpita dalla crisi ma una
crisi così profonda che veramente sta
sfibrando la società della grecia e
anche noi sappiamo bene che noi stiamo
avendo dei seri problemi in questo paese
noi la chiamiamo crisi economica forse
si potrebbe anche chiamare una
metamorfosi perché credo che la crisi
abbia evidenziato che c'erano dei nostri
problemi di sistema che non funzionava e
chi sta decidendo per noi dei giovani si
dice sempre vero che l'italia non è un
paese per il giovane deve essere strano
per me essere un giovane per le strade
di matera a camminare vedere vedersi
circondati da questo passato così
glorioso così antico però sentire anche
allo stesso tempo una depressione per il
futuro
dirsi sempre quasi sfortunati di essere
nati in un periodo che tutti dicono sia
di crisi perciò cosa stanno facendo
questi ragazzi per tanti di loro se ne
stanno andando
io vivo a londra da vent'anni è
veramente gli ultimi anni sono stati
impressionanti io sento italiano ovunque
avvocati banchieri il ragazzo che fa il
caffè c'è anche ad al jazeera nel nostro
dipartimento di finanza e una ragazza
italiana perciò veramente stanno
arrivando in tantissime io sono una
grande fan di fare delle esperienze di
lavoro all'estero ma questo è diverso
questo non è la fuga dei cervelli questa
è la fuga dei tutti tutti perché non
vedono più un futuro qui e cosa stanno
andando a cercare a londra stanno
cercando quella parola magica che noi
sentiamo tantissimo nel nostro discorso
nazionale qui in italia e quella parola
meritocrazia
noi vediamo la meritocrazia come la
soluzione a tanti dei nostri mali forse
tutti dei nostri mali iniziando
ovviamente dal nepotismo che noi
sappiamo benissimo deve cambiare che noi
sappiamo non sta dando le vere
possibilità al nostro paese ma a mio
avviso e lo dico dopo 20 anni a londra e
una vita all'estero
sfortunatamente mi è sempre mancato
l'italia non ho preso io decisione di
andarmene però e con la famiglia siamo
andati via quando avevo solo otto anni e
io credo che nel discorso nazionale
italiano se si è frainteso cosa sia in
effetti la meritocrazia perché visto
come antidoto al nepotismo e visto come
antidoto tutto è visto come la nostra
soluzione è vista come una cosa positiva
e lo è ma non è solo una cosa positiva
perché la meritocrazia anche un lato
negativo per lo meno per lo meno un lato
spiegato perché la meritocrazia come la
intendo io non premia i bravi la
meritocrazia non premia chi ha studiato
alla meritocrazia non importa niente se
hai preso 110 e lode
la meritocrazia non premia chi lavora
duro e in un certo senso la meritocrazia
non premia chi se lo merita la
meritocrazia
premia i migliori e agli altri vanno gli
avanzi a londra arrivano 5 mila persone
nuove che si trasferiscono a londra ogni
settimana e moto è un immigrazione che
amiamo insomma di livello istruito e
tutte si stanno mettendo in gara a
londra ci sono tante opportunità ma
quando c'è un lavoro mettono la
richiesta di lavoro
mille domande lavoro lo andrà a una
persona il o la migliore e perciò per me
è molto fuorviante parlare di
meritocrazia se non si parla anche delle
sue due sorelle gemelle forse non
identiche ma sicuramente sorelle gemelle
competizione e ambizione
io a volte parlo con dei ragazzi
italiani che vengono a londra e mi
chiedono barba meglio non capisco cosa
tu stai dicendo cosa vuol dire
competizione io vedo questo lavoro mandò
mio curriculum
cos'altro dovrei fare e ci ho pensato
molto insomma le domande alle risposte
che cerco di dare è mi ha fatto venire
in mente un litigio che io avevo avuto
tantissimi anni fa quando ho 20 21 anni
con un amico che si chiama matteo
italiano molto più italiano di me nel
senso che lui e anche ha viaggiato ora
dopo ma lui è nato e cresciuto in italia
e parlavamo del compito in classe e io
avevo confessato che non solo era una
tale secchiona che non avevo mai copiato
però anche che io non avevo e non avrei
mai lasciato copiare un compagno il mio
compito faccia non avrei aiutato un
compagno di classe facendogli copiare il
mio compito
apriti cielo matteo e le ha dette di
cotte e di crude ma che antipatica che
sei ma che male ti fa perché non
dovreste aiutare un amico e poi mi
diceva stai non sai mai quando sarai tu
che avrei bisogno dell'aiuto e ci ho
pensato molto veri quando si litiga con
un amico che ecco voglio dire che siamo
ancora amici ora perciò la nostra
amicizia sopravvissuto quel litigio però
quando litighi con un unico per una cosa
così bella e basilare allora pensi beh
sono io allora che ho sbagliato lui cioè
come che siamo così diversi
allora io ho pensato due anni ci sono
arrivata che era basato sul fatto che io
avendo fatto le scuole anglosassoni
durante tutta la mia istruzione
accademica i voti che venivano dati a
noi erano dati in maniera molto diversa
di quanto venivano dati a matteo che ha
fatto la scuola italiana per matteo
metti non compito in classe il voto e su
100 perciò non so dal 60 per cento e
sufficienza a 70 80 buono molto buono 6
a 90 per cento in più ea il voto ottimo
ed era basato su quello che facevi tu
non era basato sul tuo voto relativo al
voto degli altri
io invece nella scuola inglese
internazionale che ho fatto il mio voto
era un po così
questo si chiama modello di valutazione
accademica anglosassone con curva
gaussiana una maniera molto complicata
per spiegare che il mio voto invece era
relativo al voto dei miei compagni di
classe
perciò qui diciamo su trenta ragazzi una
classe di 30
come vedete dalla parte insomma a destra
solo il 10 per cento avrebbe avuto il
voto ottimo perciò su trenta ragazzi
sono tre avrebbero avuto il voto ottimo
e non importava perché tutti i voti
venivano messi su questa curva dove la
maggioranza era nel mezzo c'era
l'insufficienza e l'ottimo però solo una
certa percentuale sarebbe stata
eccellente cosa volevo dire allora che
tu potevi avere 99 per cento
come risultato di un compito in classe
ma se c'erano tre persone con 100 per
cento tu non avevi voto ottimo
questo spiega perché copiare e
socialmente accettabile nel sistema
italiano e io sto usando l'esempio del
compito in classe e poi sappiamo che a
volte si può adattare in altre
situazioni socialmente accettabile
italia e non qui perché se fai copiare
l'amico in italia tu sei simpaticone tu
sei l'amico che ha aiutato l'altro e voi
due insieme contro il sistema avete
vinto e non avete danneggiato nessun
altro se io qui metti o uno dei voti
ottimi aiuto
un amico o amica che avrebbe avuto la
sufficienza col mio aiuto salta al molto
buono non è più un crimine senza vittime
perché la gente dietro di lui vedrà il
suo voto abbassato perché io ho lasciato
copiare e allora far copiare non è più
socialmente accettabile l'opposto io non
sono più la simpaticona della classe io
sono la cretina che sta danneggiando i
voti di tutti gli altri per aiutare
qualcuno che alla fin fine non ha
studiato ora questo può sembrare un
esempio un po sempliciotto però questo
mostra come la competizione nel sistema
anglosassone dove vi ho fatto le scuole
viene insegnata interamente a 9 anni
venivo mi davano questi voti perciò
viene inculcata e io noto molto che i
ragazzi italiani non sono abituati a
questo perché questo continua non solo
la scuola tutte le università e in
america e nel regno unito sono a numero
chiuso perché mi sembra far domanda è
sempre una competizione quando fai
domanda devi dare i voti e le scuole
mostrano sempre nella pagella
se tu sei nel top 10 per cento se tu eri
fra i migliori
gli italiani non sono abituati e questo
mi dispiace molto dire che quando io
vedo arrivare il loro curriculum perché
certi mi rimandano ad al jazeera
interessati al giornalismo semplicemente
se hanno il mio contatto per chiedere un
consiglio che io sono più che contenta
di dare anzi è un onore però si vede che
non ci sono abituati perché la verità è
che i curriculum dei ragazzi italiani
mostrano che loro non sono per niente
abituati a competere non c'è frase che
mi fa arrabbiare di più di quando io
accendo un talk show in italia e si
sente la frase si all'ombra c'è
meritocrazia basta solo il curriculum
bene allora io ora vi mostro il
curriculum che mi è arrivato un paio di
mesi fa da una ragazza italiana
meno certo senso ancora meno italiana di
me lei si chiama costanza maio lei nata
perugia da genitori italiani che però si
sono trasferiti in stalla delphia in
america quando lei aveva solo sei anni
per metterla così il suo accento
italiano ancora peggio del mio comunque
ecco qui il suo curriculum costanza ha
ora 21 anni
qui 20 allora qui vediamo
tutta la istruzione l'euro
all'università di new york e ha fatto
vari stage ad abu dhabi negli emirati
arabi uniti e poi anche a parigi anno
sabbatico in spagna e questo non è
vacanza studio fine papa queste sono
tutte borse di studio e cose gratis che
lei ha vinto perciò ma questa è solo la
prima pagina questa istruzione premi e
borse di studio costanzo mi mostra
subito dove quando lei è stata
eccellente se vediamo la seconda entrata
quando dice deans liszt quelle di cosa
parlavo prima
il 10 per cento a top di una scuola o
continua guardateli il primo impatto
globale con belle donne che una
organizzazione non governativa perciò
con cui lei ha lavorato spesso perciò
non era solo ovviamente cose pagate qui
vediamo le esperienze professionali se
vedete in basso sulla destra vede chi
inizia a 18 anni
la prima esperienza professionale e
vedete anche la seconda e casa italiana
new york che credo che se andiamo a noi
ci dovremmo passare da quanto lei ha
detto lei praticamente era alla
reception
perciò non lavori che avevano un impatto
con i suoi studios che lei insomma
vedeva il suo futuro ma esperienze di
lavoro che continua esperienze
internazionali anche qui vedete 19 18 18
anni
la prima è andata in mali l'africa a 15
anni per due settimane
e qui esperienze extra accademiche tutte
le cose che faceva oltre oltre lo
studiare che le università in america
guardano perché vogliono vedere gente
che veramente attiva non solo se può
magari non essere il massimo
accademicamente però a può avere altri
interessi
e qui le sue competenze alla fine melo
mette insomma le lingue ovviamente ho
studiato e mi fa vedere ma quello che
veramente impressionante di il
curriculum di costanza e guardatelo così
ma guardate le colonne
perciò la colonna a sinistra e dai 15 ai
17 anni
poi l'altra colonna 18 anni 19 anni 20 e
21 o solo un entrata perché quando l'ho
fatto aveva appena compiuto 21 anni
guardate la colonna di sinistra 15 17
anni
questi sono lavoretti o quello che noi
definiremmo lavoretti ma sono esperienze
ed è anche la colonna in un certo senso
più farcita di cose da quella colonna
dipendono tutte le altre colonne
ora io vi dico una cosa quando io vedo i
curriculum dei ragazzi italiani che mi
mandano il curriculum all'ombra quella
colonna non esiste e non esiste neanche
veramente 18 19 anni o se esiste in
minima e ora io lo so che è molto
difficile in italia per una questione di
mentalità e noi non ci siamo abituati e
so che molte famiglie vedono anche
insomma a far lavorare i ragazzi da
giovani in maniera un pochino negativa
so anche che è molto difficile avere uno
stage e parlavo con beppe severgnini del
corriere della sera un mio caro amico e
collega e lui mi ha detto una frase che
mi ha fatto ridere che più facile fare
entrare un giaguaro nella redazione del
corriere della sera che non minorenne
perciò io so che ci sono tante
difficoltà però ogni volta che mi arriva
un curriculum di un ragazzo italiano e
io ho sempre l'istinto giustamente o
forse no di voler aiutare un italiano il
legame di sangue
però quando io lo vedo e vedo che è
abbastanza sgualcito c'è una parte di me
che vuole chiedere nell'estate dai 15 ai
17 anni perché tutta quell esperienza
estiva ego l'estate dei 15 16 7 anni
eri per tre mesi sotto l'ombrellone con
famiglia e amici nell'estate dei 18 anni
eri sotto l'ombrellone con famiglia e
amici per tre mesi
l'estate 19 20 21 anni ieri per tre mesi
sotto l'ombrellone con famiglia amici
perché se eri sotto l'ombrellone per
tutti quegli anni per tre mesi non so se
è veramente diritto di piangere a 23
anni perché non ha nessuna esperienza
lavorativa e non riesce a trovare on
stage questa
non lo dico mai ai ragazzi italiani
perché io so il contesto ma la realtà è
che loro magari quando nel curriculum a
me e io sono italiana capisco e magari
aiuto ma lo stanno se sono a londra lo
stanno mandando a gente che non è
italiana e loro non capiscono e quella è
la mentalità che daranno questa è la
competizione e io ho chiesto a costanza
che vi prometto costanza c'è vede
curriculum mi sembra una super
antipatico invece gentile brava e tanto
carina e io gli ho chiesto la costanza
cos'è che ti ti ha spronato già quando
ero piccolino a fare queste cose di chip
l ambizione
ho l'ambizione altra parola che non si
sente mai nel discorso italiano io mi
ricordo una volta alla rai e ho chiesto
parlavo con una collega di cosa
parlavamo io ho detto versa e poi io
sono ambizioso nel fatto che qualcuno lo
dico perché non posso dirlo veramente
così bisbigliavano le fa perché sembra
brutto perché nel nostro discorso essere
ambiziosi sempre brutto se un po di
arrivismo sun potrà andare sgomitare di
olgettina e poi se sei una donna dice
che sei ambiziosa e voglia però
l'ambizione chiave l'ambizione perché in
tutto questo discorso
un'altra parola che viene fuori nel
discorso italiano fa un po di privilegio
per questo tutte queste esperienze di
lavoro all'estero
quello che io sto descrivendo è la
versione diciamo forse europea del sogno
americano
il sogno americano chi era erano i
nostri antenati che mia mamma è meta sia
mia mamma ai siciliani io sono meta
siciliana nostri antenati non di secoli
fa del secolo scorso anche forse solo
dopo guerra che non avevano niente
avevano capito che qui non avrebbero
avuto futuro e l'ambizione li ha spinti
ad andare in america senza niente e la
competizione la meritocrazia ha fatto sì
che ora dopo due generazioni o quel che
sia si sentono nomi italo americani in
tutte le posizioni più alte in america
quelle l'ambizione niente a che fare con
il privilegio è l'opposto del privilegio
e la maniera per riuscire a sfondare se
non sei nato con la fortuna
ora ci sono due ragioni ci sono due
ragioni per la quale io ci tenevo di
parlare di queste cose 1 perché
veramente mi colpisce quello che sta
succedendo con tutti i ragazzi italiani
che arrivano a londra po di settimane fa
ne avevo un uomo di 31 anni ragazzo un
uomo di 31 anni che si è messo a
piangere al telefono perché veramente
così duro scontrarsi contro questo muro
soprattutto quando già si è lasciato
l'italia con un po di amarezza perciò ci
teneva un po spiegare ma non è solo una
questione di chi va perché il vero
lavoro e da fare qui
e l'italia è da cambiare qui è da
cambiare ora e forse questo sistema
forse non è giusto per noi
perciò io credo che ci sia bisogno di un
discorso di meritocrazia di usarlo in
maniera giusta e di usarlo in maniera
nostra noi non vogliamo essere una
brutta copia di paesi come il regno
unito e l'america ma vogliamo essere una
versione più giusta più competitiva
della nostra cultura per un futuro
consapevole italian style
grazie